hello everybody and welcome to part 8 of
let's play nightmare house - oh man it's
it's been a rough ride getting to hear
all but I'm gonna push forward for you
guys cuz I am so tough so tough
oh thank it is a chav information is
always very important to us here and
never lose ha ha if you have any
problems trouble or sudden aching pain
oh boy
contact our nurses at the nearest
nursing station oh they will be happy to
help you along your way
ok I bet they won't don't get up
Oh Oh who's there oh no not you back oh
you want some axe
that's what watch ok oh nothing nothing
nothing nothing oh oh what a wimp yeah
get away oh you want some too bunk bed
avenue bump chop off your head little
head Splosion alright I'm ready I'm
ready ready to get it out of here also
ready oh oh no no no no no no oh
not flashlight don't go no don't go now
ah [ __ ] you oh okay I know how to reload
guy no I know I know
you'd think that having guns would make
me feel more comfortable but somehow it
does not all right bring it I want a
shotgun
shotgun is the ideal anti-zombie
ordinance
these are bomb doors who's locked these
doors okay of course first thing to go
out during a zombie apocalypse is the
lighting who boards up the oh no no no
no no Oh finally oh my goodness
now - sniffs new Swedish okay ordering
me around I don't take kindly to that
hazardous voltage oh yeah get in there
get in there oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me okay all
right
oh no oh no no no no no oh no no no okay
all right getting out of here Oh fire
not scary
ah how you scary scary oh oh wow okay
I'll get me out of here I'll get the
other side not die die die get out of my
way go
oh that didn't do a damn thing down here
guys I'm gonna waste ammo oh boy Wow
whoa okay okay okay I got this oh it's
epically jump oh yeah
super mega awesome Oh
oh yeah I suppose if I have tried a
little harder I could have found a
better way to shut off the radio than
light everything on fire oh no don't do
it no oh god damn it oh okay
last-minute things going to stop it from
killing me yeah yeah oh oh thank you
lady oh you saved me I owe my life to
you oh man oh man my voice has been
hurting from screaming so much these
past few days I've been recording like a
lot of ah I've been recording a lot of
videos we've just been screaming
non-stop I'm gonna take a break from
horror games just to give my voice a
rest oh man all of them
I'm not no no I refuse yeah how oh no
this is still the morgue oh I can't even
say if it's not letting me save oh boy
oh-oh-oh who's there lady
oh thank you for saving my life ah oh oh
I knew it I knew it
ah Billy this is your daughter or your
wife or someone oh go away go away oh
please go oh I like your upside down oh
oh okay alright I can do this oh thank
you thanks goodness oh man yeah I am I'm
so fast
yeah oh wow yes this is alpha squad read
you loud and clear
one civilian please yes okay please get
me out of here
thank you
finally some common sense oh why me
again oh man okay my axe Oh bring it on
I'll leave you guys with an axe no oh he
was probably very dead oh yes I did oh I
remember now he was dead yeah I know you
know what you talking about bro oh man
high five to you okay where am I
oh man yup better all that scared you
not even a little bit okay guys still
here
stick with me nope that was the voice in
my head loading bay gate now opening
clear
oh don't get chopped in half guys thank
you thank you oh man all right what's
down here zombie get away you have a gas
mask
feel bad for me gosh oh okay okay
alright gotta keep up oh gotta keep my
composure I'm like scared silent
now you feel my pain oh don't lose
anyone please don't lose anyone okay all
right oh boy Oh suddenly I had an idea
that a tank was gonna come busting
through but that's the wrong game for
you oh oh they're tough up man suck it
up Oh zombies I'll bring it up evidence
oh you can't stand the hacks oh yeah
[Music]
yeah I do too many of these guys have so
much in common we'd be best buds we're
gonna die
Oh can't see a thing can't see a thing
with my flashlight
oh sorry Oh sir for the coffee I've been
fighting that back oh man just seriously
screaming so much is like killing my
voice okay okay keep going I'll bring it
bring it on guys bring it on if we lose
anyone No
down we go alright we got here still got
everyone okay three people right okay
actually I am going to cut it here thank
you guys so much
Oh what let's see what are you doing guy
okay nothing okay thank you guys so much
for watching and I will see you guys
it's part 9 of let's play nightmare
house - bye bye